hello one and all and welcome back to
the animatron 6000 our patented device
for projecting any seemingly improbable
scenario for your viewing Indulgence and
today we decided to do something
slightly different with it here at SCP
explained we usually activate the
animatron to bring you encounters
between the anomalous denizens of the
SCP universe and other fictional
characters like Doctor Strange fighting
the Scarlet king or able crossing paths
with Batman but this anomatron
experiment is one of our more unusual to
say the least if you've been subscribed
to us for a while some of you might
remember our video What If scp-096 was
put inside
scp-914 in it the shy guy was tricked
into entering the input Booth of the
anomalous refinement machine during a
Containment Breach what emerged was
maybe the handsomest man to ever live
Beautiful both on the outside and within
a lot of our comments pointed out that
this refined version of 096 felt akin to
a gigachad and that got us thinking what
if scp-096 was to encounter the real
gigachad well the animatron 6000 has a
few different answers for us scenario
one or as we like to call it the obvious
outcome pits the thin humanoid anomaly
Against The Man Behind the meme
Ernest kalamov is a Russian fitness
trainer and model forever immortalized
in the annals of Internet history by a
series of black and white photoshopped
pictures that garnered him the nickname
of gigachad thanks to his Practically
Perfect 90 degree jawline and muscular
physique kalimov's seemingly unknowingly
became the archetype for the ultra
masculine handsome man however The Man
Behind the gigachad meme is still just a
man the infamous photos of him were
heavily edited for an art project known
as Sleek in tears and while Ernest does
Sport some impressive muscles from all
his time at the gym that strength is an
enough to save him from the shy guy
after all he is still just a man
according to the animatron's predictions
the most likely outcome if the two were
ever to meet would end pretty similarly
to the Grim fate of many others who have
gazed upon the face of scp-096 the
moment Ernest looks at the creature he
would in all likelihood activate 096's
rage State his physique and above
average level of Fitness might give him
a slight Advantage allowing him to
perhaps outrun the shy guy for longer
than most but ultimately Ernest kalamov
would be able to run but not hide from
scp-096 the creature would track him
down and hone in on him with anomalous
speed dispatching him before returning
to its usual docile sobbing State the
result and
scp-096 victory now we know what you're
thinking is that really it we had the
same reaction too but hold on for a
minute after giving the machine an
additional set of variables we were able
to get a few more interesting outcomes
out of the animatron which brings us to
the result that we've given the title of
scenario 2 shy harder of course Ernest
kalamov might be the face of an internet
meme and ultimately just a very strong
Russian man in comparison to the
anomalous traits of scp-096 but the
gigachad the gigachad is more than a man
so much more than the sum of its parts
existing within the online Zack guys
since as early as 2017 the gigachad is
far more powerful than a mere mortal he
doesn't just represent idealized
standards of over-exaggerated
masculinity like the Action Movie heroes
of the 1980s the gigachad embodies those
ideas he is the very notion of a
physically perfected human specimen
given form you may not like it but Peak
Performance doesn't even come close to
the gigachad and neither does scp-096
even at the top of its game the creature
quite literally pales in comparison to
its imposing opponent in scenario 2 shy
harder the animatron 6000 predicted that
if the two were to meet the scales would
tip in the complete opposite direction
from the first outcome for that was
scp-096 against the man but against the
meme himself while this fight is no
contest as a matter of fact it's hardly
even a fight certainly not a fair one
and instead is more of an execution from
the moment the Unstoppable Tower of
muscle and perfect angular jawline that
is the gigachad clasps eyes on scp-096
it's practically the beginning of the
end the shy guy doesn't even lift brow
but gigachad can bench one million times
his own body weight in his sleep so when
scp-096 comes racing towards him intent
on killing him just for looking at it
screeching wide jogged face the Giga
chat does what the gigachan does best he
lifts grabbing scp-096 with ease as it
comes to him screeching gigachad
casually hoists the creature off the
ground although he's only using the
tiniest portion of his immense and
Infinite Strength it's more than enough
Force to send the shy guy soaring
upwards crashing through multiple
ceilings as it sent hurtling up the
numerous floors of the foundation
facility above of course being lifted is
hardly going to kill the shy guy
outright the creature is known to be
invulnerable after all but it's not like
gigachad can go down easily either don't
forget this is no mere mortal but an
internet meme incarnate and on the
internet nothing ever dies his Perpetual
existence as part of online history
aside the gigachad is so strong that no
doubt his abs could withstand the
Firepower of any conventional weapon
realizing that even if it could reach
him it couldn't even scratch the
gigachad
scp-096 would undoubtedly begin a
downward spiral the shy guy is a
creature so insecure in itself and its
appearance that it kills anyone who so
much has glances at its face in photos
so being presented with the living
embodiment of an idea it could never
even hope to attain the biceps the
perfect right angle jawline it's all too
much sending scp-096 into a complete
meltdown the creature would be
neutralized once and for all by the very
existence of the gigachad resulting in
his victory okay so we're one point to
scp-096 and one two gigachad and most
people would maybe consider leaving it
there but not us we wanted more than
that you see we quickly realized that
the animatron's second scenario was
based on a lot of earlier iterations of
the gigachad meme don't get us wrong
that version of the ultimate man could
still easily destroy the shy guy but
around March of 2021 the infamous
photoshopped images of Ernst kalamov
started to be used in slightly different
formats that's the thing about memes
they're not only Immortal forever logged
in the ancient texts of the Wayback
machine and compilation videos here on
YouTube but memes are also adaptable
they can evolve and change finding new
variations as time goes on as such the
average fan versus average enjoyer meme
saw a new use of the gigachad before the
gigachat this notion of the ideal Ultra
masculine specimen was based on let's be
honest some pretty outdated ideas about
what it means to be a man after all it
takes more than muscle to be a man not
every man or masculine presenting person
has to work out until they're built like
a brick wall perhaps the real Measure of
a Man is how sincere sensitive and
supportive you can be as well as
standing by your interests rather than
caving to Old societal standards of
masculinity and after we updated our
data the animatron 6000 was able to give
us a new revised outcome
or what we like to call scenario three
the average
scp-096 enjoyer in this projection the
gigachad's true strength isn't just his
masculine physique and his unattainable
standards instead it's in part the
inherent adaptability of his status as a
meme but also his compassion just like
before he's more than able to resist
scp-096's attacks and the creature's
insecurity comes out put on full display
when presented with gigachad sharp
jawline but rather than overcome his
anomalous adversary by fighting him this
scenario sees the gigachad comforting
the shy guy through calm empathy and
words of affirmation he reminds scp-096
that true acceptance of oneself comes
from within and that message strikes a
chord with the creature in a turn of
events none of us saw coming the
gigachad offers to help scp-096 overcome
his crippling and deadly sensor of
insecurity the pairs start using the
on-site gym together after hours when
there aren't any innocent Foundation
Personnel around there Giga Chad not
only offers to introduce scp-096 to an
exercise regimen if that's what the
creature wants but also helps the shy
guy work on his confidence they form a
friendship with scp-096 taking a liking
to working out not because it wants to
be buff like its new friend the gigachad
but more so because doing so makes it
feel more comfortable in its own skin
scp-096 gradually starts to like itself
more even eating healthier thanks to
gigachad's advice eventually the shy guy
begins looking far more content and even
starts to develop self-confidence it's
not often that a story involving scp-096
exists with the creature getting to
achieve some semblance of Happiness
while there is one that comes to mind
the very same Shy Guy story that sent us
on this particular streak of pitting it
against the gigachat in the first place
but what if we put them together would
coming across a refined scp-096 spell
the end for the gigachad or the muscular
masculine meme undo the Shy Guy's
previous happy ending well according to
the animatron 6000 neither when we last
left him after being turned into a
handsome nine foot tall man
scp-096 had just started going by the
name David
scp-978 the desired camera had been used
to photograph the refined shine guy it
showed him holding hands with a
foundation scientist responsible for his
transformation who had studied the new
and improved scp-096 in great detail she
had quite the understanding of him but
perhaps the photograph from the desire
camera was more of a metaphor than what
scp-096 or David really desired wasn't
specifically the researcher who'd
studied him but a partner who understood
him someone to call an equal entered the
gigachad a according to the calculations
made by the animatron the embodiment of
ultimate masculinity both strong and
sensitive came bursting into the
foundation facility there the moment he
and David saw each other was like the
meeting of an Unstoppable force and an
immovable object neither one rushed to
solve the encounter with violence both
the gigachad and scp-096 appreciated
each other's aesthetic appeal both were
remarkably handsome and one couldn't
bear the thought of ridding the world of
the other instead it was love at first
sight both David formerly known as
scp-096 and the gigachad fell head over
heels in love with each other and
looking at both it was not hard to see
why they were a pair of fine perfectly
chiseled fellas and they instantly hit
it off the newly established couple
enjoyed each other's company spending
time in deep conversations
scp-096 introducing his new partner to
his friends at the foundation while Gage
child was comfortable with his own
masculinity to express his feelings
towards David without fear or judgment
no relationship is perfect of course for
a short time a sliver of David's old
self re-emerged the shy guy in him
worried that perhaps his relationship
with the gigachad was based purely on
both of their extreme good looks and was
nothing more than superficial but by
being an embodiment of healthy idealized
masculinity the gigachad was able to
sense something was wrong with David and
rather do the insecure thing of letting
it Fester he addressed it directly and
they discussed the issue in a healthy
mature and constructive way not just so
they could put scp-096's worry to rest
but so that both of them could further
strengthen their relationship and grow
as people and of course gigachad wasn't
just attracted to scp-096's refined good
looks far from being superficial he
recognized that David was a complete
person beautiful both in inside and out
and loved him as a whole not just
because they were both conventionally
attractive on the surface
scp-096 and the gigachad stayed together
for the rest of their lives or as we
decided to name this fourth scenario
from the animatron happily ever after
now go and check out can scp-096 chase
its victims across the Multiverse and
scp-096 tail a lesson in power for more
scp-096